die linken morgen 22 15 bei phoenix
[Musik]
ist die welt noch zu retten
hitze dürre stürme überschwemmungen
brände der klimakollaps scheint
unausweichlich
wie sieht sie aus die zukunft unseres
planeten ist globale digitalisierung die
lösung oder teil des problems müssen wir
ganze weltregionen abschreiben hunger
kriege terror was tun für all die
menschen und die kinder sollen es doch
mal besser haben
rettende ideen sind gefragt und ein
verstehen wie die welt sich ändert
phoenix öffnet den blick für die
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
die fakten und hintergründe und zeigt
mögliche auswege auf
weil uns unsere erde alles ist aber
nicht egal
unsere zukunft unser programm
phoenix
[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln
der presseclub jörg schönenborn
dass sie dabei sind an diesem
sonntagmittag die wut wächst die
hilflosigkeit auch über die lage in der
stadt mariupol hat die tagesschau gerade
berichtet heute wird erneut versucht
einige der über 400.000 eingeschlossenen
menschen über einen sogenannten
humanitären korridor zu retten zehn tage
krieg haben europa verändert dahin ist
die illusion dass man in fest
verabredeten grenzen friedlich
zusammenleben können zehn tage krieg
haben auch unser land die bundesrepublik
deutschland verändert zum ersten mal
liefert die bundesregierung ganz
offiziell waffen an eine kriegspartei
und bundeskanzler scholz hat letzte
woche im bundestag ein 100 milliarden
euro auf rüstungs und ertüchtigung
programm für die bundeswehr verkündet
die zustimmung dazu ist breit nicht nur
in den reihen des parlaments sondern
auch in der bevölkerung wie der aktuelle
ard deutschlandtrend zeigt unser thema
heute krieg in der ukraine angst in
deutschland und das sind die gäste ich
begrüße julia weigelt freie journalistin
spezialisiert auf sicherheitspolitik
berichtet für verschiedene radiosender
zeitungen und zeitschriften herzlich
willkommen ich freue mich auf michael
thumann er leitet das moskauer büro der
wochenzeitung die zeit und ist derzeit
hier bei uns ich freue mich auf stephan
andreas casdorff publizistischer
herausgeber des tagesspiegel und sabine
adler ist wieder bei uns die arbeit für
den deutschlandfunk und war in den
letzten jahren korrespondentin unter
anderem in moskau und warschau und für
osteuropa für adler der britische
geheimdienst hat eine analyse gemacht
nach der die russen derzeit ganz gezielt
besiedelte gebiete große städte
angreifen um die moral zu brechen in
welcher phase des kriegs sind wir
das ist ganz schwer zu sagen denn wir
wissen nicht was präsident putin noch
vor hat also wir sind ganz sicherlich
nicht am ende leider nicht denn das was
wir mit bekommen zum beispiel aus mario
pohl aber auch aus kiew aus hartz iv das
ist dass die bevölkerung nicht in ruhe
gelassen wird
dass man nicht versucht
möglichst
zivile zivilisten schonen vorzugehen
wohngebiete nicht zutreffen all das ist
ja überhaupt nicht der fall das was wir
jetzt sehen sind zerstörungen genau
dieser ziele und genau die opferzahlen
die immer höher gehen
also
all das was präsident putin bislang
seinem volk erzählt ist ein einziges
lügengebilde
diese mär von der befreiung der ukraine
dass die befreiung von einer
faschistischen runter wie er das sagt
die errettung der robusten und
russischsprachigen in der ukraine
all das stimmt von vorn bis hinten nicht
und er versucht dieses lügenmärchen in
russland zu verbreiten da hat er
vielleicht auch ein bisschen erfolg
damit das ist das was wir auch
mitbekommen weil die medien jahren
praktisch jetzt eingeebnet worden sind
aber er hat ganz gewiss kein erfolg
damit wenn er glaubt dass die bilder aus
der ukraine nicht die welt erreichen das
tun sie und dafür sorgen die ukraine
nämlich jeden einzelnen tag in dem sie
ihre geschichte erzählen und ihre bilder
verbreiten hätte man in welcher phase
des krieges sind werden ich glaube wir
sind am anfang einer eines langen
krieges ich glaube dass die russische
führung und speziell präsident putin der
die größten aufklärungs dienste hat und
so viele informanten aber offenbar sind
die alle ziemlich schlecht informiert
sonst hätten sie nämlich gewusst dass
die ukraine sich tatsächlich wären
würden wenn man in irland geht und
aufgrund dieses widerstands glaube ich
dass dieser krieg lang viel länger als
die russen sich das gedacht haben wird
und ich sehe noch eine große gefahr das
was sabine adler eben erwähnte diese
rhede über die faschisten darin liegt
nämlich eine eine riesengefahr weil er
spricht von entnazifizierung und in
dieser in dieser sicht sind letztendlich
alle ukraine die sich wehren nazis und
die die sich ergeben sind halt eben
brüder nun wenn die meisten widerstand
leisten fragt sich was macht man mit
denen und die entnazifizierung
impliziert eine art von entmenschlichung
die glaube ich noch die entfesselung
allergrößter gewalt ermöglichen könnte
im weiteren verlauf des krieges das
heißt je länger er dauert desto brutaler
und blutiger wird er freilich fragen
sehen sie irgendein irgendein zeichen
der hoffnung von neuen verhandlungen der
nächsten woche ist die rede nach den
ersten beiden statements traue ich mich
kommen die frage zu stellen also ich
kann ihnen was sagen zu der idee wie
können wir denn jetzt weitermachen also
sie sprechen auch verhandlungen an wie
kann der westen sich jetzt verhalten in
dem zusammenhang und ich würde gern so
eine so eine zweierlösung
vorschlagen einerseits weiterzumachen
mit harten wirtschaftssanktionen auch
damit waffen zu liefern und andererseits
sich aber auch noch mal zu überlegen was
könnten denn so die wirklichen gründe
von putins rein und ich hab dann
definitiv nicht so eine grosse russland
expertin video beiden kollegen hier aber
wenn ich mich so versuche ihn hinein zu
denken dann denke ich mir eher möchte
anerkennung und er möchte zugehörigkeit
zu den mächtigen auf der welt gewinner
und ich nehme eine haltung war im westen
dass es auch was was präsident obama
gesagt hat dass putin oder russland eine
regionalmacht ist und ich glaube das ist
sehr verletzend für ihn und wenn der
westen ist schafft irgendwie auf diese
auf diesen aspekt einzugehen und zu
sagen jetzt bleiben hart bei unseren
grenzen souveränität von staaten ist
unantastbar und gleichzeitig versuchen
wir auf diesen punkt einzugehen wenn
makro oder von der leyen sowas sagen
würde wie
russland spielt bei der lösung aller
großen globalen krisen eine rolle dann
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass das
verhandlungsspielräume öffnet man es
wäre auch gar nicht gelogen danke also
zumindest für eine kleine perspektive
denke ich den berg gleich auch näher
darauf ein aber er kann sie zunächst
auch die frage also wo stehen wir in
welcher phase des krieges sind wir wenn
wir die bilder aus mariupol sehen und
andererseits aber auch ein des
israelischen ministerpräsidenten der
versucht zur vermittlung zur freien
einen französischen präsidenten der
telefoniert scholz hat auch telefoniert
also an welcher stelle des krieges sind
wir also anders als die beiden kollegen
würde ich sagen wir müssen erst mal
definieren was krieg ist dass es kann
sein dass es innerhalb des landes das
besetzte sollen teil besetzt ist
widerstand gegen die besatzer geben wird
wenn wir das krieg nennen gut ich glaube
dass die russische übermacht so groß ist
und die machen glaube ich militär
militärisch gesehen machen im moment
folgendes die machen eine pause die
haben festgestellt dass das was sie
jetzt gemacht haben nicht funktioniert
hat eindeutig nicht und ich glaube nicht
dass die nur dass das material fehlt
dass sie nur der treibstoff fehlt nur
die nahrung für die soldaten sollen die
haben festgestellt mit spezialtruppen
mit spitzen als mit anderen
sonderkommandos dahin zu kommen das hat
nicht funktioniert das so sind sie nicht
weiter vorgekommen also jetzt kommen sie
mit großem formierten einheiten
formieren sich neu und dann werden sie
mit größerer gewalt mit großer kraft mit
auch viel mehr firepower da reingehen
das heißt dass wir möglicherweise viel
schneller ein ende dessen sehen dass wir
jetzt sehen denn er macht ja auch keine
ich sag das mal keine gefangenen ich
meine jetzt macht er den tschetschenien
feldzug nach also jetzt wird da richtig
reingeschossen jetzt werden zivile ziele
genommen um die förderung zu
demoralisieren das ist der in der erste
teil der andere teil des angenommen er
sollte es geschafft haben ein teil der
ukraine ab zu teilen und sich dann
zufrieden zu geben weiß ich nicht genau
aber sagen wir mal so weil er nicht das
ganze land halten kann die 200.000 mann
das kann er nicht militärisch dann kann
es aber trotzdem sein dass er mit etwas
nicht gerechnet hat dass nämlich die
ukrainische nation jetzt eine nation ist
die krallen sich fest und die werden ihm
einen kriegerischen konflikt liefern
egal ob er es jetzt nicht mehr krieg
nennt oder nicht und egal welche
lösungen wir bis dahin gefunden haben
das finde ich schon interessant und das
jetzt bennett gekommen ist um sich da
einzumischen das ist ein nahezu
grenzgenial schachzug also das hätte ich
nicht gedacht dass der jetzt kommt spät
konnte aber er kommt und er hat sehr
gute kontakte in die eine wie in die
andere richtung und wenn es eines
vermittlers bedurfte es konnte scholz
nicht mehr sein
es konnte makro nicht mehr sein das
können die alle nicht mehr sein jetzt
bieten wir mal zu den verschiedenen
göttern dass das wirklich eine eine
lösung butler ja das ist die frage was
bindet sich angehört hat gestern drei
stunden lang immerhin drei stunden eher
er war geduldig er hatte sich an gehörte
aber die frage ist was vasen monolog hat
er den vortrag gekriegt den anderthalb
stunden vortrag von makro den stunden
vortrag von scholz ausgeweitet jetzt auf
ein drei stunden vortrag wir wissen es
natürlich nicht aber die große frage ist
wie empfänglich ist denn putin jetzt
überhaupt zuzuhören sendet er nur noch
oder empfängt er auch irgendwas und das
können wir natürlich nicht beurteilen
wir wissen es nicht aber
ich gebe ihnen absolut recht dass er hat
damit gerechnet ein blitzkrieg machen zu
können das szenario von außen an also
luftschläge zu vollführen und zugleich
die bodenoffensive zu starten also
wirklich mit der vollen kraft von anfang
an reinzugehen die ist nicht aufgegangen
das heißt also es ist natürlich ist
steigerungsfähig leider aber er hat
damit sozusagen schon mal ziemlich viel
gleich zu anfang in die schlacht
geworfen und er ist bis jetzt nicht
besonders weit gekommen und und ich will
noch mal eine eine szene da gerne
schildern was mir eine freundin aus kiew
geschrieben hat beziehungsweise erzählt
hat
sprachnachricht die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind wirklich
zusammen geschweißt jetzt in diesen
krieg und die die schauen auf ihre stadt
die schützen ihre stadt und das was sie
was sie auch machen das ist die so
genannte wachsamkeit und die wachsamkeit
nicht gegenüber vertretern dass man
vielleicht auch aber sie gucken sie
gucken in die straße sie gucken in die
häuser und sie gucken auf die dächer und
zb hat mir diese freundin erzählt sie
haben zwei gestalten auf dem nachbar
dach gesehen und es waren tatsächlich
russische soldaten die das dach markiert
haben für luftangriffe und haben ihre
leute also die die
territorialverteidigung aktiviert und so
weiter das heißt also eine gesamt die
bevölkerung steht dahinter und lässt
sich dieses land nicht von diesen
herrscher von diesem so genannten großen
bruder im slawischen bruder danke danke
für den versuch der lagebeschreibung
gleich ich will versuchen bis hin zu
sortieren sagt erstmal danke die sie bei
tagesschau im presseclub in den sozialen
netzwerken uns folgen danke für ihre
fragen und anmerkungen
versuche die fragen zu sortieren und ich
beginne mal damit dass werden
nacheinander die beiden aspekte die frau
bargeld auch genannt hat besprechen die
eine frage ist
wie kann der westen oder wer auch immer
eingreifen verstärken waffenlieferung
dieses thema ich lasse das im moment mal
auf seite und gehen auch mal auf das was
wir auch besprochen haben gibt es
irgendeine chance von außen einzuwirken
den konflikt zu verkürzen zu beenden zu
verhandeln auf putin einfluss zu nehmen
weil man ja ich glaube es gibt sieger
wie sie sind sehr begrenzt also man muss
sich bei allen versuchen von außen zu
vermitteln klar darüber werden der der
westen ist natürlich mittlerweile klar
partei ist nicht kriegspartei aber eher
sanktionen verhängt und putin hat das ja
schon als kriegserklärung unter anderen
mitteln bezeichnet in soweit ist muss
von dritter seite kommen und da ist
sicherlich israel da wäre auch indien da
wäre auch china es gebe da einfach eine
reihe von staaten die 30 aus den 30
staaten die sich in der un enthalten
haben wegen während über 140 staaten die
russland klar verurteilte
man muss nur bei diesen gesprächen
wissen putin putins prestige und sein
politisches überleben zu gewissen in
gewissem maße hängt an diesem krieg er
hat darin voll investiert zu 100 prozent
und er muss ihnen deshalb in irgendeiner
form siegreich zu ende bringen und das
große problem für ihn ist und das
bedeutet wir hier ja eben schon an
nochmal zur verstärkung die ukraine hat
eine historische aufstands tradition
nach dem ersten weltkrieg als es einen
ukrainischen nationalstaat gehabt haben
die bolschewiki damals jahrelang dieser
aufstandsbewegung niederkämpfen müssen
und das auch manchmal vergessen wird
auch nach dem zweiten weltkrieg gab das
bis in die 50er jahre wurde gekämpft in
der ukraine das heißt und das wird nach
30 jahren eigenem nationalstaaten noch
stärker sein deshalb meine ich und das
würde ich als krieg bezeichnen eher
casdorff die das ist tatsächlich
ein paar diesen krieg oder wie auch
immer eine solche das ist das problem
der verhandlung und das was wir
erreichen müssen in dieser phase ist das
in diese großen umkämpften städte
hilfsmittel kommen das land ist von drei
seiten umstellt es kann nur noch von
westen kommen und dass diese korridore
frei bleiben ansonsten werden wir große
humanitäre katastrophe walter kasper
ihre frage war ja was können wir machen
immer wieder diskutiert wird so nötiger
oder wer auch immer also wo man sagt ja
also den besten also nicht die ruhe
vielleicht
ich glaube das thema flugverbotszone das
wird nicht kommen ich habe die debatte
auch auf twitter mitverfolgte hat einen
zuschauer gefragt kann denn eigentlich
auch die uno eine flugverbotszone
verhängen oder kann das nur die nato das
kann auch die uno nach artikel 42 der un
charta wir hatten einige
flugverbotszonen in den 90er jahren im
irak im kosovo 2011 in libyen meine
einschätzung ist die nato hat schon
gesagt sie wird das nicht machen und die
uno wird das natürlich erst recht nicht
machen weil russland im sicherheitsrat
ein veto hat also ich glaube nicht dass
das passieren wird ich möchte aber
nochmal anschließen das was die kollegen
gesagt hat ist putin überhaupt
aufnahmefähig hat er sich das an und da
möchte ich wirklich mein punkt noch mal
wiederholen was können wir denn machen
dass er
aufnahmefähiger wird die chancen erhöhen
und ich glaube von
militärischer seite aus wird das
schwierig werden ich erhalte wirklich
groß ich habe wirklich eine gewisse
zuversicht wenn wir uns diplomatisch auf
diesen punkt anerkennung nochmal
fokussieren er möchte diese anerkennung
des westens natürlich vor allen dingen
der usa wir könnten aber auch von
europäischer seite aus schauen was
können wir tun um eines nicht viele
jahre jetzt gescheitert ist das nicht
die strategie gewesen die vor allem von
der deutschen politik verfolgt wurde ich
glaube das was verfolgt wurde
gerade von deutschland wahr handel durch
wandel das ist aber etwas anderes als
anerkennung wenn ich von ihnen ein auto
kaufe oder sie von mir ein auto kaufe ja
das ist ein wirtschaftlicher vertrag in
dem fall gebe ich ihnen ja keine
anerkennung also ich würde wirklich noch
mal gucken steinmeier war nicht als
handlungsreisender nun als ein
außenminister der immer wieder um groß
ist verstehen wie können wir einerseits
unsere grenzen klar halten auch mit
wirtschaftssanktionen auch mit militär
und andererseits wie können wir putin
entgegenkommen und ich weiß dass das ein
harter gedanke ist morgana castor ja ich
wünsche mir auch hier könnten ihm
irgendwie entgegenkommen aber minsk 1
und 2 und die ganzen diplomatischen
versuche das ist nicht so einfach denn
die forderung der gestellt von denen
geht nicht aber ich möchte nur sagen ich
glaube den sieg müssen wir ihn
definieren lassen weil er ich zeige dass
man etwas zugespitzt psychopathologische
wird und narzisstisch und die wahl er
kann manipulieren kann lügen er handelt
ja verantwortungslos und risikobereit dh
wir müssen versuchen ihm irgendwie das
gefühl zu geben dass er dann doch noch
einen sieg definieren kann wie auch
immer man das machen will allerdings
dürfe den sieg nicht zu lassen und darin
liegt die schwierigkeit
flugverbotszone muss sich die nato sein
sondern es kann auch ganz anders laufen
andreas umlandt dieser professor der im
netz auch tätig war
oxford palo alto also wirklich
substantiiert auch in kiew gut aber der
sagt man kann das auch ganz anders
machen wir keinen menschen zur ukraine
erklären und 14 15 16 18 dahin schicken
und dann haben wir eine flugverbotszone
die von ukrainischen piloten gesichert
wird vielleicht müssen wir anders denken
aber ich will nicht zu militärisch
militaristisch werden wichtig ist dass
der westen eindeutig geschlossen bleibt
und das ist ja schon toll was er da
erreicht hat der putin das muss man
schon sagen so geschlossen waren wir
glaube ich seit jahrzehnten noch bei der
frage ob es irgendein einfach jahres
ansatz viel aus ich glaube ja also ich
glaube jahre geschlossen
mit dem hinweis darauf dass es
möglichkeiten der zusammenarbeit gibt
die wir dann gemeinsam erörtern also in
drei körben die er ja selber aufgemacht
hat nato russland
bilaterales verhältnis zu amerika es
hilft nix weil dass er einen
ansprechpartner ist und
ungeteilte sicherheit in europa was was
konkret verstehst du darunter und nicht
mit maximalforderungen wenn wir auf
diese drei körbe eingehen wie wir der
casa de früher okay also in schweden
klassischer
gesprächspartnern ja was noch zu
probieren ist während wirtschafts
wirtschaftssanktionen was wir ja noch
nicht ausgereizt haben bis zum schluss
das ist eine möglichkeit ist das nicht
der diplomatischen ansatz nachdem sie
fragen aber das ist eine
handlungsmöglichkeit die der westen noch
hat also sprich gasöl verkauf eben
wirklich stoppen der also den kauf
stoppen importe stoppen das ist eine
möglichkeit die gefällt uns nicht
natürlich nicht aber ich glaube der
preis wird sehr viel höher werden wenn
wir weiter zu warten und dann die
auswirkungen einer noch höher gerüsteten
russischen armee erleben also dass das
wäre eine möglichkeit und es gibt
natürlich auch noch die andere
möglichkeit massiv die russische
zivilgesellschaft zu ermutigen zu
unterstützen das ist im moment extrem
schwierig dass es völlig klar aber im
grunde genommen die wirkliche lösung
liegt in der russischen
zivilgesellschaft niemand anders das
ja dann lassen sie uns über
weitere eingriffsmöglichkeiten über
militärische optionen wie man das so
schön entsprechen also wie
waffenlieferungen die selbst die
bundesregierung jetzt beschlossen hat
wir treffen vielleicht nicht die
kriegsentscheidenden waffen sie haben
interessanterweise gesagt hatte man der
westen seien nicht partei
völkerrechtlich ist man das nicht wenn
man mache nicht kriegspartei das schon
partei ich genau nicht also
völkerrechtlich habe ich gelernt ist man
das nicht wenn man waffen liefert man
wird damit nicht zur kriegspartei
der ukrainische präsident lenski tut
alles um uns zur partei zu machen weil
er sagt wir kämpfen für euch wir
erhalten für euch die russische armee
auf jetzt tut ihr auch was für uns also
lassen sie uns über militärische
eingriffe reden das stichwort flugverbot
dass man durch satz ist schon gefallen
lieferung von kampfjets die dann wer
auch immer fliegt ist etwas was in
diesen tagen wieder diskutiert wird
ist der besten ist die nato sind wir
moralisch verpflichtet wenn wir die
entwicklung in den städten dort sehen
stärker militärisch einzugreifen
also die moralische verpflichtung die
definiert sich am ende dadurch was wir
tun und ich glaube man darf die
sanktionen die bisher verhängt sind
überhaupt nicht unterschätzen sie sind
wesentlich stärker als alle das bisher
erwartet haben die politiker selbst sie
verhängen sind über war überrascht was
da plötzlich alles kommt und werden von
sich selbst quasi überholt mittlerweile
ist ein teil der politischen kriegskasse
eingefroren die zentralbank es sind
eingefroren die können das nicht
verkaufen die dollar und die rohre das
ist eine sehr harte maßnahmen okay dann
sage ich
sie frage stellen solidarisieren ja wir
sehen welches elend in den städten
passiert wir schauen zu wie dann wenn
wasser und strom und lebensmittel weg
sind sag mal dass das elend zunehmend
wir schauen zu wie städte bombardiert
werden wir haben einen ukrainischen
präsidenten der sagt wir tun das doch
für euch wir kämpfen für eure werte
und wir diskutieren ob wir die
wirtschaftssanktionen schneider ein
bisschen stärker
als ich noch ein paar wochen dann genau
hat ein dass er ich glaube dass darüber
hinaus eine flugverbotszone
klingt so neutral ist ein ganz klarer
ein eingreifen in diesem krieg dann
müssen deutsche tornados vorab fliegen
dann kommen die amerikaner und die
briten hinterher wir sind dann voll im
krieg und die frage ist und für die
ukraine tatsächlich dann entlasten
würden wenn wir uns tatsächlich in die
große auseinandersetzung
begeben würden deren schauplatz zunächst
mal die ukraine wäre ich weiß nicht ob
das im interesse der städte dort ist ich
glaube die in dieser lage zu verhandeln
dass da ständig hilfs korridore
reinkommen ist wichtiger bei
gleichzeitiger aufrechterhaltung
maximalen drucks auf putins kriegskasse
und seine möglichkeiten dort mehr
material ein zu
also ich glaube was wirklich möglich
wäre jetzt ist die ukraine zu beliefern
mit leicht handhabbaren waffen das heißt
also diese territorialverteidigung die
eben ja maßgeblich dafür da ist die
städte zu verteidigen dass die waffen
bekommt um also flugabwehrwaffen
abwehrwaffen
uci bekommen sie die müssen erstmal zum
teil sind sie schon da aber sie müssen
auch nachgeliefert werden denn auch die
werden verbraucht die werden zerstört
wenn wir wir sind uns relativ einig am
tisch dass das nicht morgen zu ende sein
wird und auch nicht wie der viel an die
mäder finnland krieg nach 40 tagen
mutmaßlich wird es nicht also nichts
sieht danach aus im moment also das
heißt es muss ein auf lange sicht ein
waffennachschub kommen und es muss es
müssen warten sei nicht hoch
spezialisierte waffen sondern waffen die
eine bevölkerung leicht anwenden kann
also eigentlich ältere fahrer castorf
also ich stelle mir das tatsächlich vor
das ist ein signal dass mich auch
bedrängt was ist wenn wir sehen und
sagen wir auch gott ja es tut uns
furchtbar leid wir können nichts tun da
wird die politik unter druck geraten so
war wie ich hier sitze so wird es sein
die politik wird sich neu überlegen
müssen ob sie nicht doch eingreift und
ich sage so umwege wie umland also eine
flugverbotszone mit anderer hilfe
durchsetzen damit wenig kriegspartei
werden was ist wenn wir eine luftbrücke
nach kiew machen angenommen die
bundesdeutsche luftwaffe fliegt eine
luftbrücke nach ihr sind wir dann
kriegspartei oder nicht dass muss ihre
hilfs korridor aha das muss geklärt sein
ist das ein hilfs korrektur gut aber was
ist wenn die maschine abgeschossen wird
wie reagieren wir dann die reagiert die
nato ist das ein angriff auf die nato
das sind alles fragen die jetzt geklärt
werden müssen und zwar nicht erst wenn
wir das gefühl haben wir müssen was tun
denn es kann tatsächlich passieren dass
wir bei accident sage ich jetzt mal was
ein amerikanisch da hineingezogen werden
natürlich wünscht sich seelands geht
dass er meint ist gar nicht böse sondern
er will diese nation die da entstanden
ist der will die retten und das verstehe
ich will einfach nicht dass sie jetzt
auseinander fällt in eigentliches
jährigen konflikt aber an dass immer un
ja aber das ist sie froh ist un
luftbrücke und so weiter das war ein
sarajevo so der jahre aber in sich
entschuldigen sich als jahren reitet
russland ja dass aktien gerade eine
flugverbotszone und denn den eintritt
von einem nato-mitglied zb deutschland
zum beispiel andere nationen der nato in
den krieg als kriegspartei haben jetzt
gerade den unterschied gelernt zwischen
parteien kriegspartei
die politiker und politikerinnen der
einzelnen nationen haben ja eine
verantwortung ihren bürgern gegenüber
auch dem bündnis aber in erster linie
ihren bürgern gegenüber und keiner hat
er hier am tisch sitzt kann sicher sein
dass wenn wir wirklich als kriegspartei
deutschland die nato die eu wie auch
immer als kriegspartei sich engagiert
der krieg nicht wirklich
sich ausbreitet und putin wirklich das
was er sagt auch macht und wirklich
andere länder soll
das will keiner aber ich finde das muss
man wirklich auch noch mal klar sagen
was sind dann die konsequenzen davon wir
können das nicht ausschließen wollen wir
das wirklich will die bevölkerung wollen
die menschen die jetzt eine
flugverbotszone fordern und auch ich
finde es furchtbar die bilder die ich
sehe und ich gucke mir an weil ich sie
wirklich sehen will weil ich wirklich
auch für will wie es den leuten geht
aber es denen geholfen wenn noch mehr
menschen leiden also wir sagen denn
aushalten schwierig aushalten ich habe
keine einfache antwort für sie hätten
also ich habe ich aber habe zwei auf die
konsequenzen hin weil er ich habe zwei
fragen gestellt auf die sie alle keine
überzeugende antwort haben die auch
sonst niemand der sich damit glaube ich
gerade politisch und diplomatisch
beschäftigt nämlich wie kann auf dem
verhandlungswege schnell etwas erreicht
werden die könnte militärisch das elend
das sterben schnell beendet werden
trotzdem
hinzufügen dass wir haben bisher
flugverbotszonen diskutiert in kriegen
bei starten wie in syrien die weit
unterlegen waren wir haben es im post
jugoslawien beim zerfall jugoslawiens
gemacht hier haben wir es einfach zu tun
mit einer einer atommacht der wehr eine
flugverbotszone aufzwängen würden das
ist eine große entscheidung und ein
großer sprung und lässt völlig anders
als bei us la vie interview ich bin ich
dafür unsere diskussion ist
selbstlosigkeit in der wir sind weil wir
eben
weder als westliches bündnis noch als
bundesrepublik dort eine lösung kennen
zu spenden hilfslieferungen zu machen
ist glaube ich ein versuch etwas zu tun
irgendwie auch sagt mir das gewissen zu
erleichtern aber
ard-deutschlandtrend diese woche
auch in der bevölkerung in deutschland
hat sich die stimmung was button
lieferungen angeht deutlich gedreht wir
sehen im februar vor beginn dieses
krieges waren es nur 20 prozent die
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine direkt
durch die bundesregierung unterstützt
haben jetzt ist es eine deutliche
mehrheit von 61 prozent dieser
stimmungswandel dass dieses doch sehr
pazifistisch geprägte land deutschland
jetzt doch auf einen anderen politik
kurs schwenkt das scheint etwas zu sein
was moment breite unterstützung findet
er das wort zeitenwende ist oft genannt
worden nehmen wir als bundesrepublik und
jetzt blicken wir mal über die nächsten
fünf bis zehn tage dieses krieges hinaus
nehmen wir plötzlich eine andere rolle
heim werden auch wir zu einem land das
seine politik auch mit militärischer
stärke begleitet also ich glaube wir
haben ein wandel vollzogen der
überfällig ist gewesen ist dass dieses
sich zurücklehnen und zurückziehen mit
dieser moralische überheblichkeit zu
sagen unsere geschichte erlaubt uns das
nicht das war eine
fadenscheinige und so untaugliche
ausrede die wirklich schon nicht mehr zu
ertragen war in euren in ihrer in ihrer
doppelmoral die daten enthalten war das
finde ich eine wirklich ganz ganz
wichtige entscheidung zu sagen unsere
historische verantwortung ist es zu
handeln und nicht zuzusehen und die
anderen zu mahnen und die andere
geschichte ist die dass es endlich
aufhört
andere nicht nur die schmutzarbeit
machen zu lassen wenn es um verteidigung
geht sondern auch zahlen zu lassen also
stichwort 2%
verteidigungsausgaben
und endlich mal das nato ziel den
eigenen beitrag zur finanzierung zu
erbringen und auch da nicht aus der
scheinbar moralische überhöhten position
zu kommen ja wir sind ja die pazifisten
wir brauchen das nicht wir sind in dem
die eigentlich die guten wir sind nicht
eigentlich die guten sondern wir waren
ganz schöne egoisten verwandelt konkret
2% 100 milliarden das was er scholz
jetzt vorgeschlagen hat was ja noch
einen weiten weg auch durchs parlament
gehen muss was heißt das konkret was
wären wir dann für eine republik was
hätten wir für eine bundeswehr wir
hätten eine bundeswehr die mehr die
chance hat wirklich auch verteidigungs
fähig zu sein wir haben eine starke
aussage dass inspekteur des heeres
alfons mais gelesen der gesagt hat das
heer stehe mehr oder weniger blank da
das ist schon eine krasse aussage und
100 milliarden zusätzlich zu den zwei
prozent ja nochmal die soll ergeben das
geld ist wichtig dass stimmlich der
kollege hinzu wir haben schon häufig
gehört wofür soll das ausgegeben werden
für material ja da haben wir schon
gehört beschaffungsprozesse müssen ich
effektiver werden effizienter und so
weiter stimmig komplett zu was in der
debatte um diese
verteidigungsausgaben meiner meinung
nach aber fehlt ist der aspekt personal
die bundeswehr hat ein fünftel der
dienstposten der bundeswehr oberhalb der
mannschaften ist nicht besetzt aktuell 1
5 lassen über 20.000 stellen das beste
gerät nutzt einfach nichts wenn es nicht
ausreichen soldatinnen soldaten gibt die
das gerät einsetzen können die truppe
muss als arbeitgeber wirklich
attraktiver werden und soll davon allein
ist dafür ausgelacht worden als sie so
was wie wlan in kasernen gesagt hat aber
welcher junge mensch geht dann zu
irgendeinem arbeitgeber in schwarzenborn
auf den knüll wo er keinen wlan hat also
das ist einfach super wichtig dass das
eine und das zweite ist wir brauchen
eine truppe und der sich auch die
soldatinnen und soldaten wertgeschätzt
fühlen das ist super wichtig es gibt
eine bundeswehr umfrage von 2020 dass
sich das soldatin und den eindruck haben
150 prozent leisten zu müssen um
anerkannt zu werden dass eine bundeswehr
eigene studie und wir müssen einfach
optimale dienst bedingungen für
bundeswehrangehörige schaffen sonst
nutzt auch noch so viel geld nicht sind
sie niemanden haben der das gerät
benutzt am ende der castor ich habe frau
bargeld jetzt so verstanden dass sie das
sehr unterstützt was scholz aufgerufen
hat tun sie das auch bei dieser zweiten
bände dieser 180 grad kurswechsel jetzt
mutig und richtig wie also wenn wenn
überhaupt irgendein zeitpunkt dann jetzt
ich hab auch schon mal gesessen
epochenbruch sich nur eine zeitenwende
denn tatsächlich ist es das was war da
sagt wie wohl ich widerspreche
jahrzehnte der zurückhaltung lassen sich
nicht weg kommandieren und es war ganz
gut dass wir deutsch aus den
knobelbecher rausgekommen sind das
wollten nämlich alle jetzt sind wir aus
den knobelbecher raus und jetzt finde
die leute auch nicht so richtig gut ja
wir werden eine andere verantwortung
wahrnehmen müssen und diese 100
milliarden plus jährlich zwei prozent in
der nato ich will nur darauf hinweisen
wie es jetzt schon dass wir haben jetzt
schon den siebtgrößten
militärhaushalt in der welt den
siebtgrößten ist nicht so als ob er gar
nichts ausgeben über über 50 milliarden
von 34 kommt das ist viel wir sind der
zweitgrößte truppensteller in der nato
ist es nicht so als ob die deutschen gar
nichts getan hätten richtig ist dass die
bundeswehr jetzt ausgestattet werden
muss damit sie ihre aufgaben in einer
veränderten welt mit mehr verantwortung
wahrnehmen kann nicht mehr nicht weniger
von aufrüstung zu sprechen dass auch
wieder falsch es ist ausrüstung die
notwendig ist und jetzt wird das
nachgeholt was nicht was da vorher nicht
wahr und es ist auch nicht richtig zu
sagen dass wir das nicht gesehen hätten
nach der krim aktion hat die damalige
verteidigungsminister ursula von der
leyen 2014 eine trendwende finanzen
eingeleitet okay es ist nicht alles zu
gelaufen es hat nicht alles geklappt das
hat was mit wirklich dem mit mit der
arbeit zu tun das beschaffungsamt also
die beschafft das beschaffungswesen der
finden hunderte stellen da würde ich mal
reingucken wohl sagen so das muss jetzt
anders gehen aber richtig ist es ist
erkannt die umsetzung ist das schwierige
und das ist genauso wie sie sagten bei
dem sondervermögen von 100 milliarden so
ein fachmann sagt nach 100 milliarden
ich glaube die grünen waren überrascht
die werden auch noch diskussion haben
die spd wird auch noch diskussionen
haben obwohl jetzt der bundeskanzler
gesagt wir machen das so und ist ja
durchaus folgsam aber es ist die
umsetzung daher schwierig ich würde
gerne einen aspekt noch hinzufügen die
zeitenwende sehe ich vor allem in der
anerkennung der notwendigkeit in der
bevölkerung also die politiker die
fachleute die bundeswehr die wussten
dass längst aber es war
dass ressentiments in der bevölkerung
die zurückhaltung die einfach noch
angehalten hat die bevölkerung war der
war es nicht zu vermitteln denn der etat
zu erhöhen die spd hat sich sehr es wird
worden und die politiker haben dieses
gefühl in der bevölkerung ja auch
verstärkt oder haben das land immer so
ist er an die themen außerhalb weil sie
haben die themen raus gehalten weil sie
wussten wenn wir mit einem höheren mit
der forderung nach einem deutlich
höheren also zwei über zwei prozent zwei
prozent ziehen in den wahlkampf gehen
als spd laufen uns die wähler weg und
jetzt ist es anders jetzt ist die gefahr
so sehr mit der hand zu greifen auch in
deutschland jetzt haben die menschen
einfach angst und wissen wir müssen
jetzt teilt 2014 hat ein
bundesverteidigungsminister schauen wir
noch mal mit ihnen zusammen aus dem ard
deutschlandtrend ganz kurz das thema
zwei prozent ziel an also es geht um die
nato gegebene verpflichtung 2 prozent
des
bruttoinlandsprodukts im bundeshaushalt
für rüstungs und wer ausgaben aufzurufen
und sie sehen 69 prozent sagen ja das
ist richtig
zurück zu der diskussion die wir gerade
hatten
stimmungen sind ja ein bisschen wie der
wind also manchmal wen sie konstant aus
der einen oder anderen richtung und dann
drehen sie sich auch wieder wir haben
gerade über die parteien gesprochen also
wir haben jetzt eine regierungspartei
spd die das in weiten teilen überhaupt
nicht befördert hat wir haben eine
regierungspartei grüne die das bis auf
einzelne stimmen überhaupt nicht
befördert hat wir haben eine
regierungspartei fdp die weniger staat
und weniger ausgaben wollte also wie
glaubwürdig wie nachhaltig wie sicher
ist dass das jetzt passiert
die kriegen sicherlich noch in den
parteien diskussionen aber ich halte es
eigentlich für einen ganz glücklichen
zufall dass das gerade zusammen fällt
mit dem antritt dieser neuen regierung
insoweit weil wer wäre denn jetzt besser
geeignet bei seinen eigenen leuten und
wlan zwei prozent für die bundeswehr
durchzusetzen als die spd die 2013 und
2017 dagegen wahlkampf gemacht hat mal
nach diesen boney m star und ja du bist
aber zugesagt hat und dass zweitens die
halt form von steinmeier kann sich 14
genau zwei prozent zugestimmt hatte auf
dem nato außenminister treffen aber das
hier ist eben das entscheidende die am
jetzt die chance ihre leute mitzunehmen
und mich erinnert das eben auch an
damals als rot grün 1998 antrat und
wenige monate nach antritt
regierungsantritt schon sich im kosovo
krieg befand und wesentliche
außenpolitische entscheidungen treffen
musste und hier kommt noch ein aspekt
hinzu und das ist das interessante
außenpolitische die außenpolitische
wirkung es wird ja im ausland als
revolution deutsche außenpolitische
revolution bezeichnet und das hat
durchaus auch ein charakter davon weil
nämlich die die deutschen haben gerade
salto gemacht aus deren sicht wir sind
plötzlich vor die welle gekommen und
standen im grunde genommen in den
letzten jahren immer so ein bisschen auf
der bücher bank und letztendlich ist das
auch eine art von befreiungsschlag wird
natürlich geschaut wie wir das am ende
auch umsetzen werden aber ich denke es
war auch außenpolitisch ein sehr kluger
schritt mit einem mal ist die kritik an
den deutschen in dieser frage vom tisch
geräumt ich würde gerne
auch dieses thema abschließen weil es
eine von vielen fragen ist die wir seit
zehn tagen diskutieren und ja weil es
viele versuche sind und wir nicht wissen
wohin es am ende politisch führt ich
habe parallel danke für die vielen
fragen und anmerkungen parallel gelesen
was viele im publikum
beschäftigt und ich formuliere mal oder
übernehme die formulierung von von
angelika sturm bei facebook und die
fanden jetzt löffler auf youtube das
sind sehr grundsätzliche fragen die
glaube ich durch unser aller köpfe gehen
angelika sturm fragt ist ein dritter
weltkrieg jetzt auszuschließen nils
löffler schreibt möchte eine ehrliche
antwort ich sitze hier zu hause und
mache mir riesige sorgen wegen eines
nuklear kriegs gibt es einen atomkrieg
dass ich mal all die details der
diplomatie und politik die wir
besprochen haben weg und ja ich weiß
dass sie die frage nicht beantworten
können dabei trotzdem würde ich mir
wünschen dass wir eine runde noch machen
die diese gravierenden
sehr nachvollziehbaren ängste aufgreift
die hier formuliert werden wer möchte
beginnen
ich würde beginnen wir wissen es nicht
ob es diesen krieg gibt natürlich nicht
wir können sehen wie der präsident
agiert
und nur er nur präsident putin würde
diesen dritten weltkrieg auslösen
niemand anders
was wirklich bedenklich ist ist dass er
einen kompletten realitätsverlust
erlitten hat komplett er weiß nicht dass
er mit diesem er weiß dass
wahrscheinlich aber er nimmt es nicht
wahr dass er mit diesem vorgehen die
ukraine natürlich nicht in das russische
imperium zurück holt er weiß dass er mit
diesem vorgehen natürlich nicht die welt
von der großartigkeit russlands
überzeugt das heißt all das was er
gerade macht seine handlungen
widersprechen exakt dem was er
eigentlich möchte mehr anerkennung mehr
respekt
ist der welt seinen willen aufzwingen ja
dass das das schafft er damit dass es
möglich und das
steigert leider die kriegsgefahr
kann der kollegin zustimmen wir wissen
es nicht
ich möchte aber noch mal einen punkt
machen zu diesem thema angst wir haben
ja auch die sendung oder sie haben die
sendung auch sogenannte deutschland hat
angst
und die hörerinnen hörer zuhörer das
betont ich lese in sozialen netzwerken
immer wieder
informationen dazu was kann man machen
wenn es wenn man angst hat ja
nachrichtenkonsum vielleicht
einschränken sich um sich selber kümmern
und diese auf der anderen seite dann
menschen die das verurteilen und sagen
in der ukraine sterben die leute und ihr
sorgt euch hier um eure seelische
gesundheit reißt euch mal ein bisschen
zusammen da will ich nochmal klar machen
und auch vielleicht in richtung der
zuschauenden diese rechnung von wegen 20
deutsche panikattacken lösen ja helfen
ja nicht einem ukrainischen soldaten
also ich finde es total wichtig sich um
sich selbst zu kümmern sich selbst zu
sorgen und dann
auch handlungsfähig zu werden und zu
entscheiden was mache ich gehe ich
vielleicht auf eine demo spende ich
vielleicht was informiere ich mich und
sich da nur so ein bisschen im blick
dank schließt einreden zu lassen
herr kaster und haltungen ein gedenkt
all das was ich gehört habe möchte ich
mir selber nicht untreu werden also ich
verwende sagte wir müssen diplomatisch
auf diesem noch gesprächs werde alles
versuchen ich glaube es ist die
verantwortung des so genannten freien
westens alles zu tun sprich alles zu
unterlassen was zu einem dritten
weltkrieg führen kann das heißt du musst
eingedenk dessen was jetzt vor adler
gesagt hat dass psychopathologische an
wladimir putin wohin auch immer er will
wo eben auch er sich sieht wer sein will
müssen wir das eingedenk alles
unterlassen was diesem dritten weltkrieg
entfesseln kann denn wer als erster
schießt stirbt als zweiter aber wir
stehen mir macht es nicht macht es
natürlich auch sehr unruhig seit der
atom drohung von putin und der
gefechtsbereitschaft dir erklärt hat wir
müssen wissen es ist die stufe zwei von
vier stufen
da ist noch ein bisschen luft die frage
wenn man jetzt einfach nur die vernunft
anlegt putin merkt gerade er ist in der
ukraine in einem krieg in dem er sich
verkennt und das noch lange dauern wird
es wäre jetzt absolut unvernünftig eine
zweite große front zu eröffnen bevor er
das vollendet hat und insoweit gibt mir
das so ein bisschen wenn denn die von
uns noch regiert im kreml gibt mir das
ein bisschen hoffnung dass diese
eskalation so schnell nicht kommt danke
schön ich hätte mir vor kurzem nicht
träumen lassen dass ich diese frage mal
zum schluss der sendung stelle und dass
keiner der gäste sie klar mit nein
beantworten kann bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für diese diskussion in der ard
geht es weiter mit dem europamagazin das
auf die aktuelle lage in der ukraine im
kriegsgebiet schaut und bei phoenix und
wdr 5 presseclub nachgefragt mit ihren
fragen oder anmerkungen danke bisherigen
schuss aus köln und lassen sie ist
beginnen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im radio bei wdr 5 im
fernsehen bei phoenix und geht beginnen
in osterburg in der altmark martin rauer
ist in der sendung danke für den anruf
bekommen
im hinblick auf die bündnistreue der
nato also besitz der fall mutigen 35
plant ein mitleidiger drogen seiner
atomwaffen einzusetzen die
bündnispartner vor allem im hinblick auf
die vereinigten staaten vielen dank ja
danke wer mag
bündnistreue kann ich was sagen es gibt
ja zwei
bündnisse einmal die nato im nato
artikel nato vertrag artikel 5 steht
dass mitglieder
die maßnahmen ergreifen müssen die sie
für erforderlich halten um die
sicherheit wieder herzustellen
es gibt auch noch den artikel 42 des
eu-vertrages darin steht dass
mitgliedstaaten alles in ihrer macht
stehende unternehmen müssen um
angegriffene staaten zu zu unterstützen
letztendlich bleibt es aber dann doch
jedem mitgliedsstaat selber überlassen
wie inwieweit er unterstützung leistet
danke möchte jemand noch eine andere
antwort geben es wird einen beistand
geben denn andernfalls hätte die nato
das ende erlebt es bleibt gar kein
anderer weg als in der geeigneten art
und weise mit allem ihrem in allem ihrer
macht stehende zu reagieren weil sonst
die nato sich sofort auflösen kann herr
raue danke groß nach osterburg wir gehen
weiter nach krefeld roca werner guten
tag herr werner
nicht interessiert eigentlich warum die
nato oder der gesamte westen den
generälen und offizieren von putin nicht
einfach ein lukratives angebot machen
zum beispiel reichtum zusicherung von
straffreiheit wenn sie den krieg beenden
würden
das ist so die frage herr tormann
ist das umfeld wirklich so treu oder
kann man dort maßgebliche personen für
sich gewinnen ja das ist die wirklich
eine million dollar frage
was wir wissen ist dass das umfeld
bisher sehr treu und loyal ist und dass
es überhaupt auch die eintrittskarte in
den engeren kreis um putin herum man
zahlt mit 100-prozentiger loyalität so
jetzt die frage bleibt das so weil
tatsächlich derzeit ein gewaltiger druck
auf der russischen gesellschaft und auch
auf der russischen elite lastet die ja
überwiegend bis in den engsten kreis
hinein überrascht wurde von dem was
putin da entschieden hat und das in
tateinheit mit den von uns allen
gesehenen erniedrigungen öffentlichen
erniedrigung seiner engsten mitarbeiter
zum beispiel des auslands
geheimdienstchefs in harrys gehen und da
ist die frage was macht das mit so einem
nadeschkin und bröckelt womöglich hinter
der fassade die loyalität und das ist
natürlich der moment wo man angebote
machen kann wobei ich stelle mir gerade
zumal wenn es hilft abgeschaltet ist wie
soll man lukrative angebote rüber
bekommt also da muss man sich etwas sehr
raffiniertes überlegen aber das ist
vielleicht eine möglichkeit in der
zukunft ich würde gern noch ergänzen
wollen jeder der jetzt in frage käme als
derjenige der eventuell putin in den arm
fallen könnte wäre ein kopf kürzer und
zwar sehr schnell also dass der sich
jetzt niemand aus der deckung wagt das
find ich das gehört ja zu dieser eher
schwer denkbar zu dieser clique auch zu
dieser herrscher clique aber auch bis in
die haarspitzen hinein ist es ja auch so
dass die
verwandt und verschwägert ist mit
ukraine also es gibt ja kaum eine
russische familie die nicht zumindest
ukrainische freunde oder auch verwandte
hat also man weiß er ganz genau auch in
diesen kreisen was da abgeht und dann
dritte bemerkung dann sehen aber auch
anderen punkt weil eigentlich verspreche
ich immer dass man eine person heilung
hörer und hörerinnen antwort ich genug
da habe ich jetzt schon eine ausnahme
gemacht danke schön
und jetzt klaus-rüdiger martin in
braunschweig guten tag herr martin der
hund tag meine frage ist ist es denn so
schlimm wenn die ukraine wirklich
neutral und sogar in magnet
entmilitarisiert ist denn neutralen
schweden finnland österreich und
man könnte ja dann diese neutrale
quatsch ukraine genauso beschützen wie
jetzt durch diese sanktionen die die
äußerst stark sind und ganz kurz zu
grimm will das will ich kurz noch
loswerden
denn wenn russland sich die creme nicht
unter den nagel gerissen hätte müsste
die
müsste russland miete bezahlen pacht
bezahlen für die krim
gegenüber ukraine wenn die ukraine zur
nato wäre müsste russland miete bezahlen
verbesserte marco pohl
gegenüber der nato helmut wäre ja danke
ich finde der erste zentrale punkt ich
weiß aus den rückmeldungen das ist ganz
vielen userin usern auch durch den kopf
geht also wir haben sie es formuliert
wäre es so schlimm wenn die ukrainerin
radikalisiert am neutral wäre erst wenn
putin keinen angriffskrieg entfesselt
hätte um völkischen nationalismus zu
verfolgen und ex zu expandieren imperial
dann hätte das eine möglichkeit sein
können in verhandlungen tatsächlich die
finlandia sierung der ukraine aber
inzwischen sind finnland und schweden
auf dem weg in die nato also da hat sich
auch wieder eine axt verschiebung
ergeben die wollen jetzt auch nicht mehr
alles mitmachen oder dem ausgesetzt sein
ich weiß nicht ob das nicht im
hintergrund immer noch eine rolle spielt
kann sein dass das war ja die frage was
können wir ihnen anbieten das kann sein
dass das dass es im zuge der diskussion
über ungeteilte sicherheit in europa
eine rolle spielt aber im moment sieht
es nicht danach aus herr martin putin
während bieten damit das ist die frage
womit ist er zufrieden
das müssen wir wissen herr martin ich
bin ihnen dankbar wir einige sendungen
den letzten hatten gehabt das
gegenargument war immer der brief aus
dem oktober in dem seine forderungen
viel weitreichender waren aber es bleibt
eine zentrale frage danke russ nach
braunschweig
oerlinghausen ist die nächste station in
ostwestfalen haxl steller guten tag
guten tag in die runde
ich erinnere mich an die an die zeit
kurz vor dem einmarsch weil wir uns
vorher unisono war immer zu hören von
allen führenden schuldig bekannt ja wir
wissen nicht was putin vor hat ich hab
das damals schon und auch im nachhinein
wenn man sieht wozu er geschlossen
braucht sich offensichtlich auch vom gut
vorbereitet hat
dass die dass die gesamte dass die
gesamte
diplomatie ratlos waren und ich frage
mich wie konnte es dazu kommen
und ich finde dass die diplomatie auch
eine mitschuld trägt dadurch eine
verantwortung zumindest weil es
offensichtlich im vorfeld
keinen austausch gab bei 24
mitgliedstaaten mit entsprechend vielen
außenministern mit dem ganzen apparat
dahinter habe ich mich wie konnte es
kommen und dann in den blick in die
zukunft gerichtet
hoffentlich wird und wirklich noch mal
auf der suche nach einer lösung da ich
jetzt ganz ganz viel kreativität auch
der diplomatischen seite gefragt also
ich bin ihnen dankbar für die frage zum
halbjahr zu dem bild auch dazu gehört
dass der us-geheimdienst ich glaube
mindestens zweimal sehr konkret den
bevorstehenden einmal genannt hat bis
hin zu einem bestimmten mittwoch an dem
das stattfinden sollte und trotzdem ist
ja ihr eindruck verbreitet dass die
diplomatie nicht vorbereitet war da ich
frater zuletzt unterbrochen hatte würde
ich sagen ist radler dann
also man hat ganz viel kommen sehen der
auf wachs von
militärischer ausrüstung
von soldaten
entlang der
russisch ukrainischen grenze bis hoch
zur belle russischen grenze hat der
stadt gefunden in den letzten monaten
wir haben im april vorigen jahres das
erste mal von 30.000 soldaten gesprochen
es ging die zahlen ging immer nur weiter
nach oben ein manöver löste das andere
ab mit immer mehr soldaten an der grenze
das heißt also die gefahr konnte man
sehr wohl sehen und hier hat man auch
gesehen und ich würde jetzt auch nicht
zustimmt dass es keine diplomatischen
bemühungen gegeben hat die hat es auch
gegeben also ins gespräch zu kommen so
habe ich nicht verstanden sondern sein
eindruck war dass die diplomatie von
diesem schritt überrascht war
von dies von diesem krieg vor einiger
zeit also habe ich gar nicht verstanden
erschüttern sie sind ja noch da ja also
ich hab mal so lag kann ich natürlich
sagen was für meinen punkt spricht dass
er geht nicht fehlt wenn die dinge wenn
die dinge wenn die dinge gesehen wurden
wenn man wenn man es vermutet hat
letztendlich ist mein statement nur ist
wurde nicht verhindert ich konnte nicht
verhindert werden okay
dafür geht man konnte ja dafür gibt es
ein grund herr schütte
es alle wussten was putin wollte man
musste einfach nur seine forderungen
lesen erstens unterwerfung der ukraine
zweitens rückzug der amerikaner aus
europa abzug der atomwaffen er wollte
mit anderen worten kontrolle über europa
er möchte die vereinigten staaten als
sicherheitsgarant europas ablösen das
ist das was er möchte hatte
aufgeschrieben und man hat darüber ganz
viel geredet und konnte sich
wundersamerweise nicht einigen weil das
halt unvereinbare positionen sind hier
trifft etwas ganz hart hart aufeinander
und wir können uns darüber nicht einigen
und deshalb stehen wir in dieser
auseinandersetzung
bedanke mich herzlich herr schütte groß
nach oerlinghausen und
in tutzing ist ausklappen berger dabei
alles klappen berger ja guten tag ihres
ausgaben berger herzliche grüße aus
tutzing am starnberger see
ich sehe nur eine einzige chance den
krieg herr zu werden und zwar auf
diplomatischem weg man ist sich ina
einschalten die putin und des druck
setzen könnten und sich selbst zur wahl
als friedensmacht zu inszenieren sehen
sie das als möglichkeit er kann was zur
rolle nicht sagen können oder wollen
sagen wir so jinping ist also eher nimmt
zweieinhalb leute offensichtlich nur
ernst wladimir putin einer davon ist
ganz sicher schießen ging weil die auch
eng verflochten sind russland china und
wenn die chinesen den daumen senken die
sind sehr eng verflochten dann wird
möglicherweise putin sein haupt senken
müssen insofern ist es ein muss es ein
zentraler punkt sein da hin zu gucken
und man muss jetzt eigentlich ein
emissär zu skijumping schicken der die
ich sage mal die genügend einfluss auf
ihn hat mindestens das nachdenken
darüber anzustoßen darauf hat der westen
allerdings keinen einfluss also dass ein
scheidet ina ganz allein ob es das
machen möchte oder nicht klar aber es
gibt durchaus vermittler die ich im auge
habe die sogar aus deutschland kommen
könnten und in china die freunde des
chinesischen volkes
von
angela merkel vielleicht klappen berger
bedanke mich
dann nehmen wir
hadek in düsseldorf in die sendung guten
tag guten tag in die runde ich sehe eine
ganz große gefahr darin dass
politikerinnen und politiker immer
wieder drohen gewährten aufbauen also zb
100 milliarden zu nennen immer wieder zu
wiederholen dabei darauf hinzuweisen
dass die bundeswehr es in wien in
einigen jahren schlagkräftig ist zu
betonen dass man statt drei jetzt nix
eurofighter ins baltikum schickt da
schickt er die freiwillige feuerwehr um
moskau sowas zu nehmen da sehe ich eine
ganz große gefahr in diesen wolken die
da aufgebaut werden ob man das nicht
anders gestalten kann ein bisschen
zurückhaltend da okay wir lassen es
einfach mal so stehen ist ihre meinungen
danke
tschüss nach düsseldorf
dann gehen wir zu holger stein in mühsam
guten tag
willkommen
schön dass sie dabei sind
einfach wenn der vorsprung hier sagt
hier geht wie hoch das wort ist wie und
warum wird radikalste nicht durchgesetzt
ich erinnere mich an donnerstagen die
sendung markus lanz die neubauer mit vor
ort wo täglich werden circa 500 bis 600
millionen
dollar an russland überwiesenen aufgrund
von gaslieferungen bei ihnen lässt da
unten hier immer durch gazprom liefert
nach wie vor über die ukraine und meine
dank dass nur wir könnten uns
solidarisch zeigen dass wir sorgen
gefahren herunter gleich könnte die
regierung der kanzlerin zellen ab montag
fahren wir alle bis 900 auf der autobahn
um treibstoffe rohstoffe zu sparen die
nächste frau wäre bloß wie lange wurde
europa damit spielen bei so einer
situation der sola maßnahme radikalen
maßnahme einfach den geldhahn abzudrehen
wäre meine gedanken
bedanke mich herr stein wer mag das sofa
bei der welt also dass das ist ja eine
der optionen die tatsächlich auf dem
tisch liegen und auch diskutiert werden
ich glaube man muss einfach nur auf zwei
sachen achten erstens man muss sich weil
sie sprechen ja darüber letztendlich öl
und gas von unserer seite
abzuschalten den öl und gas zufluss aus
russland darauf muss man sich ein
bisschen vorbereiten und ich würde der
bundesregierung der gern noch ein paar
wochen gegeben denn es ist schwer genug
überhaupt diesen seiten ihrer
energiewende herzustellen vor denen sie
jetzt stehen
zweitens glaube ich dass man sich auch
in der eskalation ein paar schritte
überlegen muss und ein paar stiche die
man noch in der hinterhand halt in der
hinterhand hält nicht gleich alles aus
spielen aber das liegt auf dem tisch
danke herr stein
wollten sie noch brauchen wir doch mal
rein kommen ja ja so oder so erst ein
schuss und schönen gruß
josef dütsch im gästebuch fragt welche
auswirkungen hätte eine verurteilung
putins durch den internationalen
strafgerichtshof
wobei ich anfügen würde wie schnell kann
das gehen
in aller regel waren konflikte erst zu
ende dann musste man denjenigen finden
weil sich solche leute gerne verstecken
nach solchen kriegen und dann müssen sie
muss in der prozess gemacht werden und
sie müssen diese prozesszeit auch noch
überleben also das heißt die
verurteilung von wladimir putin als
kriegsverbrecher die weiterhin sehr und
spät kommen im moment gibt es also im
grunde nur die wirkung des signals dass
die ermittlungen begonnen haben bedanke
mich sehr herzlich bei ihnen am tisch
bei ihnen zu hause und im netz und ja
sagen guten tag aus köln tschüss und
alles gute
vielen herzlichen
[Musik]